lo que suele ser un camping popular
repleto de juerguistas veraniegos es
ahora un símbolo de las brutales
tormentas que arrasaron la isla francesa
de córcega el jueves las intensas
lluvias y los vientos de grado de
tormenta tropical arrasaron la isla
paradisíaca arrancando árboles y
destrozando campings en una visita a uno
de los lugares afectados el ministro
francés del interior prometió ayuda a
los damnificados
quiero decir a córcega a las familias y
en particular a las familias de los
turistas que han muerto o han resultado
gravemente heridos que el estado expresa
su apoyo y su compasión desde esta
mañana el gobierno y los funcionarios
locales trabajan para salvar rescatar y
mientras hablo y evaluar este terrible
incidente meteorológico
y
las violentas tormentas sin precedentes
en la isla produjeron vientos de hasta
224 kilómetros por hora dejando al menos
5 muertos decenas de heridos y decenas
de miles de personas sin electricidad
mientras tanto más de 5 mil personas
fueron evacuadas de los campings de la
isla y cientos de turistas se vieron
obligados a pasar la noche en refugios
improvisados
acabamos de llegar al campamento ya que
aterrizamos en calvià a media tarde
aunque lo peor que había pasado cuando
llegamos nos dijeron que teníamos que
preparar lo mínimo para poder evacuar
por la noche
con la previsión de que el clima mejore
las autoridades locales esperan que los
turistas puedan volver a sus campamentos
a última hora del viernes